[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka ein abend der
ukrainische aussenminister verglich
kürzlich den kampf um den don was mit
den schlachten des zweiten weltkriegs in
der tat schaut man sich videos vom
aktuellen kriegsgeschehen an die
soldaten aus schützengräben
herausschießen oder mit blattwerk
getarnte panzer in waldlichtungen lauern
könnte man tatsächlich meinen man sieht
bilder aus dem zweiten oder sogar aus
dem ersten weltkrieg auch die
zerstörungen sind grauenhafte deserves
ganze städte und dörfer in schutt und
asche
die russische armee konzentriert sich
dabei auf den osten und will dort
offenbar mit allen mitteln erzwingen was
sie anderswo nicht gelangen die ukraine
befürchten dass als nächstes wieder
städte im süden massiv angegriffen
werden und dort ist unser reporter
johannes hano
ein angler idyllen jetzt noch lust etwa
50 kilometer südlich
von hier ist es nicht mehr allzuweit
nach moldawien und rumänien
die diele aber trügt der krieg ist auch
hier längst angekommen
wir sind alle angespannt und nervös
jeden tag hören wir die sirenen wir
warten alle darauf dass unsere truppen
die gegenoffensive starten und der krieg
zu ende geht
nicht weit von hier in der flussmündung
haben mehrere russische cruise missiles
abgefeuert von strategischen bombern und
kriegsschiffen eine strategisch wichtige
brücke zerstört über die der nachschub
aus rumänien lief aus sicherheitsgründen
dürfen wir sie nicht zeigen jetzt läuft
die versorgung über kleine landstraßen
über einen umweg aus moldawien man kann
nur ahnen was unter den plan steckt in
der millionenmetropole odessa haben sie
mit der bedrohung zu leben gelernt
regelmäßig heulen die sirenen über der
stadt die menschen aber ignorieren den
luft aller das sei die größte gefahr für
die menschen denn mehrfach seit beginn
des krieges wurden auch zivile gebäude
von raketen getroffen
wir sollten die gefahr nicht
unterschätzen sagt uns der sprecher des
gouverneurs
das ist gefährlich in der stadt die
raketen können jederzeit einschlagen
auch hier wo wir jetzt stehen aber ein
es ist auch ganz klar wir werden nicht
aufgeben wir werden gewitter
an der küste suchen ukrainische truppen
den horizont ab weil guten wetter könne
man sie sehen die russischen
kriegsschiffe die weit draußen froh dass
er kreuzen wir sind in einer der
unzähligen befestigungsanlagen der stadt
wie bereiten sie sich auf eine russische
landungsoperation vor
beginn des krieges damit gerechnet dass
sie kommen wir verstärken und befestigen
unsere anlagen jeden tag
auch wenn es derzeit ruhig sei nur
deshalb die ruhe sei trügerisch meinen
die soldaten die russischen truppen
hätten oder besser als ziel nicht
aufgegeben
an manchen tagen schicken sie 2030
drohnen über unsere stellungen
ein paar hätten sie hier schon vom
himmel geschossen immer wieder stehen
drohen ukrainische verteidigungsanlagen
aus der ukrainische geheimdienst warnt
die bevölkerung die kriegsschiffe und u
boote vor der küste hätten gerade neue
raketen geladen und deshalb ist für den
krieg seien im kreml ein strategisch
wichtiges ziel
tja dann schalten wir dort zu johannes
hano johannes heißt es im bericht gerade
gesagt und deshalb wäre für die russen
wirklich ein enorm wichtiges ziel
ja und das ist für die ukraine das tor
zur welt das ist der größte hafen hier
wird er meist der handel abgewickelt es
geht ihr um getreide sonnenblumenkerne
für die ganze welt das geht hier in
diesem hafen vor allen dingen auch um
industriegüter die eingeführt werden und
wollte mir putin hat eigentlich nie ein
hehl daraus gemacht dass er odessa
einnehmen möchte dann sein großes ziel
ist es die ukraine vom seezugang
abzuschneiden das hat er immer wieder
gesagt und die ukraine befürchten dass
er genau das auch vor hat und man wir
hören ja immer wieder dass die ukraine
sagt wir werden alles nach vorne an die
front schmeißen um diese stadt zu
verteidigen denn langfristig hätte ein
verlust dieser stadt schwere ökonomische
und politische folgen für die ukraine
ein bisschen einen krieg entscheidet
sich immer auch an der logistik das gilt
natürlich für beide seiten es war eben
im bericht schon die rede davon wie
problematisch ist es für die ukraine
inzwischen den nachschub zu organisieren
also die russischen truppen haben in der
vergangenen woche massive raketen
angriffe auf die infrastruktur der
ukraine gestartet es sind mehrere
bahnlinien getroffen worden viele
fabriken sind zerstört worden aber auch
raffinerien und man spürt dass hier das
benzin wird knapp es ist rationiert
viele tankstellen haben geschlossen dass
diese der diesel wird gebraucht für das
militär an der front man kriegt ihr nur
15 liter ungefähr am tag wenn man
überhaupt benzin bekommt und dann gibt
es natürlich auch noch ganz andere
probleme nämlich hier die der der
nachschub den militärischen nachschub
als vieles ist auch was aus der
europäischen union gekommen ist wohl
auch über die brücke gekommen die über
die wir im beitrag gesprochen haben die
richtung rumänien führt die ist zerstört
jetzt muss das alles über kleine straßen
in moldawien laufen und das ist
natürlich sehr schwer das alles über
landwege hierher zu transportieren das
militär hat uns aber gesagt noch sei der
nachschub gesichert man hätte keine
probleme vor allem die leichten waffen
kämen hier an womit man allerdings große
probleme hat das sind die schweren
waffen die würden viel zu spät kommen
denn man sieht dass die russischen
truppen nicht weit von ungefähr 140
kilometer in carson massive einheiten
zusammen ziehen und man rechnet damit
dass irgendwann ein angriff kommen wird
dankeschön johannes nach odessa
auch der wirtschaftskrieg geht weiter
die eu versucht weiterhin sich auf ein
öl embargo gegen russland zu einigen
besser gesagt sie will versuchen ungarns
viktor orban doch noch an bord zu holen
ihm haben die ukraine an zuletzt
übrigens mehr oder weniger subtil
gedroht die ölpipeline aus der ungarn
sein öl beziehen laufen durch die
ukraine
und da könne man leider nicht
ausschließen dass mit der pipeline etwas
passiert
während über dem eu gipfel also noch der
schatten des zweifels hängt was dabei
herumkommt haben die g7 staaten bei
ihrem treffen in berlin heute eine
einigung erzielt die sieben führenden
industrieländer bekennen sich erstmals
geschlossen zum kohleausstieg das wird
mancherorts eine herausforderung
berichtet karl hinterleitner
glas für industrie und haushalte schon
seit 400 jahren produziert der
mittelständische familienbetrieb heinz
im thüringischen neuhaus angesichts der
rekord steigerung der energiepreise
fürchtet die chefin erstmals um die
zukunft ihres unternehmens
es trifft uns schon extrem wir sind sehr
energieintensiv wir brauchen viel gas
viel strom und mit zu zehnfachen preisen
an wirtschaften zu müssen ist eine
enorme herausforderung
wirtschaftlich und gleichzeitig grün
sein ausgerechnet am ehemaligen
gasometer in berlin ging es darum fremde
7 gipfel der umwelt und energieminister
man müsse weg von fossilen energien und
obwohl deutschland sie weiterhin
importiert städte dass die energiewende
nicht in frage behandeln aus der not
heraus das ist ja völlig klar und all
das ist ja im moment tun ist nichts auf
das ich persönlich stolz bin sondern es
ist einfach nur eine vorsorge um einen
potentiellen notfall abzuwehren und es
ist ganz wichtig dass man jetzt sehr
aufpassen muss dass man nicht überall
wie der fossile energien aufbau und
ausbaut und stärker fördert das wollte
man auch auf dem gipfel verhindern
brachte aber vor allem unverbindliches
auf den weg so soll die stromversorgung
bis 2035 überwiegend ohne fossile
energien auskommen der straßenverkehr in
hohem maße bis 2030 100 milliarden euro
sollen für klimaschutz in
entwicklungsländern fliessen und die
sieben wichtigsten industrieländer
erklärt und zwar erstmals aus der kohle
auszusteigen ein festes datum gibt es
aber nicht die umweltministerin zieht
der noch positive bilanz es war ein
gutes treffen es war gut sich persönlich
zu treffen ich fahre mit einem guten
gefühl heute nachmittag nach hause denn
dieses g7 treffen war ein erfolg für den
klimaschutz für den naturschutz und auch
für den umweltschutz vor allem die usa
und deutschland wollen gemeinsam
vorangehen beim ausbau erneuerbarer
energien und unterzeichneten heute
entsprechende absichtserklärungen
kritiker stimmt dabei wie beim ganzen g7
zwar die richtung die umsetzung aber
müsse besser werden als nach früheren
gipfeltreffen
mittel bis langfristig muss diese in
partnerschaft mit bedeuten dass man sich
gemeinsam auf klimaschutzziele nicht nur
einige die haben wir ja auch welches
pariser abkommen bereits sondern dass
man schneller solche ziele auch
gemeinsam umsetzen umweltorganisationen
sind die erklärungen zu unkonkret die
beschlüsse des gipfels gehen ihnen nicht
weit genug sie werden immer noch nicht
ihrer internationalen verantwortung
gerecht dafür ist es notwendig dass die
g7 sich verbindlich zu einem
kohleausstieg bis zum jahr 2030 bekennen
und auch ab dem jahr 2030 keine pkw mit
verbrennungsmotor mehr neu zulassen und
exportieren für mehr klimaschutz ist im
prinzip auch die unternehmerin kaletta
heinz doch noch sind erneuerbare nicht
ausreichend da und erst einmal braucht
sie vor allem bezahlbare energie der mit
ihr 400-jährige traditionsbetrieb auch
weiter überleben kann
nach dem schulmassaker in texas tobt in
den usa wieder eine debatte über das
waffenrecht
das ist ja jedes mal so und die
argumente sind altbekannt die demokraten
wollen die waffengesetze verschärfen und
generell weniger waffen im land die
republikaner hingegen folgenden
argumenten der waffenlobby gerade solche
schießereien zeigten doch dass sich
jeder bürger verteidigen können muss man
n hat sich wieder als präsident nach
einem schul amoklauf in florida forderte
dass lehrer besser bewaffnet werden
diese ist schon sehr spezielle logik
pass allerdings gar nicht gut zu dem was
jetzt über den tatverlauf und texas ans
licht kommt offenbar trauten sich sogar
bewaffnete polizisten anfangs nicht sich
dem täter entgegen zu stellen claudia
benz berichtet
halten amerikas waffenfetischisten innen
nach wieder 21 toten 19 davon
grundschulkinder die mächtige
waffenlobby nrw trifft sich in diesen
minuten in texas auch donald trump wird
erwartet viele politiker vor allem
republikaner hängen an ihrem tropf sie
beklagen dass die demokraten die
schießerei politisch ausschlachten
wollen für schärfere waffengesetze aber
nicht mit ihnen
wir brauchen mehr schusswaffen und mehr
sicherheit waffen schützen menschen die
kirchenglocken
waffen töten nicht menschen töten
von welchem sender sind sie deutsches
fernsehen das ist eine kulturelle sache
das werdet ihr nie verstehen
bei den hinterbliebenen der ermordeten
kinder kommt zur trauer nun die wut
eltern waren bereits vor der schule als
der täter noch darin war und 40
polizisten hätten dort gestanden aber
nichts unternommen eltern flehten die
polizei an ihre kinder zu retten wurden
jedoch zurückgedrängt
die leute sagten geht rein schnapp den
geht rein jede minute hat er getötet
jeden moment boom aber niemand wollte
sich in gefahr bringen also sind sie
nicht reingegangen diese kinder hätten
nicht sterben müssen
nach zwölf minuten erreichten die ersten
polizisten den tatort flüchteten aber
vor den schüssen des täters auch die
verstärkung der bundespolizei soll
zunächst vom einsatzleiter daran
gehindert worden seien in die schule
einzudringen er dachte der täter habe
sich verbarrikadiert kinder seien nicht
in gefahr herzzerreißende anrufe eines
kleinen mädchens erreichen die polizei
aus dem klassenzimmer
12 uhr drei anrufe dauerte eine minute
und 23 sekunden
sie sagte ihren namen und flüsterte sie
sei in raum 1 12
214 sie ruft wieder an weist auf mehrere
tote hin
die 12 uhr 43 und 12 47 sie bitte sofort
die polizei zu schicken aber
erst 20 minuten danach greifen die
beamten zu
rückblickend war das natürlich die
falsche entscheidung punkt und es gibt
dafür keine entschuldigung aber
gibt es konsequenzen im parlament traf
sich eine gruppe von senatoren
republikaner und demokraten
sie wollen über die waffengesetze
sprechen was keinesfalls zur debatte
steht ein waffenverbot
und jetzt macht als bei 1 weiter mit den
nachrichten
bundeskanzler scholz war heute beim
katholikentag in stuttgart in einer rede
verurteilte er erneut den krieg
russlands in der ukraine und erläuterte
die haltung und das vorgehen der
bundesregierung
und deshalb ist für mich ganz ganz klar
putin darf mit seinem zynischen menschen
verachtenden krieg nicht durchkommen
daher auch die harten sanktionen gegen
russland daher die unterstützung der
ukraine
humanitär wirtschaftlich und mit vielen
finanzmitteln und daher auch die
lieferung von waffen in ein solches
kriegsgebiet etwas das wir als
bundesrepublik noch nie getan haben
als zweite ministerin seit beginn des
krieges ist entwicklungsministerin
schulze in die ukraine gereist sie
besuchte den schwer zerstörten kiefer
vor ort borodjanka und sagte hilfe beim
wiederaufbau zu etwa für wohnungen und
stromleitungen und man dürfe nicht erst
warten so schulze bis der krieg zu ende
sei man müsse jetzt wieder anfangen zu
helfen und aufzubauen
die polizei in köln ermittelt gegen 70
tatverdächtige die zahlreiche fotos und
videos von sexualisierter gewalt an
babys und kleinkindern besessen und
getauscht haben sollen
ausgangspunkt ist ein verfahren in
berlin wo bei ermittlungen ein mann aus
nordrhein-westfalen entdeckt wurde der
listen mit mutmaßlichen pädokriminellen
geführt hat staatsanwaltschaft und
polizei wollen am montag auf einer
pressekonferenz über weitere
einzelheiten zu den ermittlungen
informieren
die iranischen revolutionsgarden haben
im persischen golf zwei griechische
öltanker festgesetzt die schiffe hätten
maritime vorschriften missachtet hieß es
zur begründung
griechenland protestierte gegen das
vorgehen und sprach von einem akt der
piraterie
vorausgegangen war ein streit beider
länder um einen tanker mit iranischen öl
an bord der vor kurzem in griechischen
gewässern festgesetzt worden war
in der demokratischen republik kongo
sind angesichts neuer heftiger kämpfe
zwischen der regierung und tutsi
rebellen zehntausende menschen auf der
flucht das un flüchtlingshilfswerk
zeigte sich besorgt über die insgesamt
rund 72.000 vertriebenen im nordosten
des landes für viele fehle es an
unterkünften sowie ein lebensmitteln und
sauberem wasser seit ende vergangenen
jahres gibt es zwischen
regierungstruppen und einer tussi
rebellenorganisation immer wieder kämpfe
wie geht es eigentlich mit corona weiter
das thema ist ja nicht vorbei über die
pandemie aktuell von anderen
katastrophen überlagert wird aktuell
sinkender zahlen zwar jedoch macht sich
nicht nur der bundesgesundheitsminister
sorgen
mit blick auf den herbst lauterbach
würde dann gerne wieder maßnahmen
einführen können also etwa masken
pflicht in innenräumen das ist
allerdings gar nicht nach dem geschmack
der fdp und so rumpelt es wieder in der
ampel der wahl wird immer deutlicher
dass durchseuchung nicht wie von manchen
erhofft dazu führt dass die immunität
der bevölkerung rasant ansteigt man kann
sich leider auch immer wieder aufs neue
anstecken petra otto über die
sogenannten re infektionen
drei mal geimpft und zwei mal infiziert
mit corona jessica reisinger ist 27
kerngesund hatte von re infektionen wohl
gehört war aber doch überrascht klar war
schon mehr bewusst dass man sich jetzt
auch anstecken kann wo man davor einfach
nicht so sehr von ausgegangen ist
eigentlich auch gedacht es wäre jetzt
durch dabei ist das gar nicht so selten
zweimal corona im stuttgarter
gesundheitsamt haben sie jetzt daten
ausgewertet und die zeigen ihre
infektionen also mehrfach ansteckungen
nehmen zu drastisch sogar seit omikron
die oberhand hat seit jahresbeginn und
fast jede dritte infektion betrifft
junger erwachsener es aber als organ
verwunderlich weil es einfach die
altersgruppe ist die viele
sozialkontakte hat und mobil ist und
entsprechend sehen wir eben auch bei
reden infektionen keine vermiete
krankheit sperre und auch keine
häufigeren krankenhausaufenthalte und
für neue nutzer statistik dann sieht man
dass die älteren menschen relativ selten
reflektionen haben und auch gut
geschützt sind sie erklären eine ganze
menge diese daten eine repräsentative
wissenschaftliche studie aber ist das
nicht valide forschung zum thema re
infektion kommt aus england dänemark
auch qatar deutschland dagegen habe ein
manifestes strukturproblem meinte
medizin statistiker gerd antes
daten hat ist das gut für stuttgart wir
wollen ja ein gesamtbild haben für ganz
deutschland gerade auch aufgrund der
unterschiedlichen impfraten und deswegen
fehlt einfach dieses übergeordnete
koordinieren und das ist von der ersten
sekunde an so wie reagiert denn ihr
immunsystem auf das virus waren die
impfungen sinnlos hier in der virologie
in düsseldorf untersuchen sie die der
körper das virus abfährt anders als beim
asam einmal masern und nie wieder
reichen bei corona wohl einmal erworbene
antikörper nicht aus und das ist für
atemwegsinfektionen ganz typisch diese
immunität die wir aufbauen die ist in
der regel nicht so dass sie in den
schleimhäuten ganz lange bleibt und das
ist dann schon so dass wir natürlich
immer wieder auch mit den gleichen
erregern dann in kontakt kommen und dann
auch wieder infektionen erleben dabei
dachten viele eine impfung oder eine
infektion und wir werden die pandemie so
gut wie los jessica reisinger hatte
zumindest leichte verläufe und sie hat
wohl niemanden angesteckt sie ist sich
sicher dass es gut war geimpft zu sein
auch wenn sie ja schon zweimal erwischt
hat
online bestellen stadt in einen laden zu
gehen das haben der pandemie natürlich
noch mehr leute gemacht doch da könnte
es für die kunden jetzt änderungen geben
heinz ja bislang ist die kostenlose
retouren gang und gäbe und wird von
kunden erwartet wie der bundesverband e
commerce und versandhandel der
süddeutschen zeitung gesagt hat und die
frage gerade bei mode wie es damit
weitergeht sina mainitz an der börse was
tut sich da im versandhandel da tut sich
einiges denn das hin und her bei
online-bestellungen soll künftig
zumindest erschwert werden die spanische
modekette zara und die japanische uni
klo machen es vor und verhängen nun für
ihre retouren knapp zwei bis knapp 3
euro pro paket transportverpackung
personal all das hat seinen preis und an
diesen kosten soll der kunde mit
beteiligt werden auf den bestellungen im
internet folgt oft der rückgabe boom mit
einer quote von 75 prozent ist
deutschland retouren europameister bei
modeartikeln beträgt der anteil 50
prozent das bedeutet 800 1000 pakete pro
tag werden an die firmen zurückgeschickt
ein kostenfaktor vor allem aber raubbau
an der umwelt und nachhaltigkeit die co2
bilanz bedeutet umgerechnet
255 mal von frankfurt am main nach
peking mit dem aus zu fahren pro tag
wohlgemerkt die ersten unternehmen
machen schluss mit kostenlosen rückgaben
händler wie amazon zalando oder otto
haben sich bislang dagegen ausgesprochen
bei ihnen sollen retouren bis auf
weiteres kostenlos bleiben nicht retour
sondern steil bergauf ging es heute am
deutschen aktienmarkt der dax beendet
den handel mehr als anderthalb prozent
im plus bei einem stand von 14
1462 punkten und damit ist das
börsenbarometer am brückentag auf einem
5 wochenhoch angelangt anleger blicken
optimistischer auf die letzten
handelstage des wonnemonats mai sind am
1 vielen dank
bei den french open hat angelique kerber
das achtelfinale verpasst sie verlor
ihre drittrunden spielt gegen aleksandra
so wird aus belarus alexander zverev hat
den einzug ins viertelfinale ins
achtelfinale geschafft mit seinem sieg
gegen den us amerikaner brandon
nakashima
der fc liverpool und real madrid
bereiten sich auf das finale der
champions league vor morgen im stade de
france in paris der final abend live im
zdf 20 uhr 25 und schon um 19 uhr 20 das
champions league magazin
so mancher verbindet ein gefühl der
sehnsucht mit paris sportlich gilt das
auch für die beiden besten europäischen
fußball mannschaften jürgen klopps
liverpooler stehen bereits zum dritten
mal innerhalb von nur fünf jahren im
finale der königsklasse
gegner real madrid ist der
rekordchampion und vergessen das finale
dieser beiden teams 2018 dass die reds
unglücklich verloren
ich werde mich logischerweise viel
besser fühlen wenn wir diesmal gewinnen
und im moment mache ich mir
ausschließlich darüber gedanken wie wir
das schaffen können
nach dem gewinn der beiden nationalen
pokal könnte liverpool morgen den
dritten saison titel einfahren
bei den filmfestspielen in cannes löst
mit die größte begeisterung ausgerechnet
ein film aus der gar nicht im wettbewerb
läuft dort aber weltpremiere feierte die
kritiker kritikerin überschlagen sich
geradezu vor lob auch unsere szene us
den sabine schulz findet ihn absolut
großartig und das will was heißen auch
wegen des jungen schauspielers der sich
an diese legende herantraut wie spielt
man elvis presley wer kann so singen
sich so bewegen ohne wie eine parodie zu
wirken nun einer kontos und nach der
premiere scheint sicher new star is born
elvis ist aber nicht die einzige
hauptfigur dieses films sein manager
spielt auch eine erhebliche rolle und
seine frau priscilla
priscilla presley mit 77 in cannes zur
filmpremiere über die liebe ihres lebens
elvis von kultregisseur passformen der
australier mit der unverkennbaren
handschrift noch eher unbekannt doch
nicht mehr lange austin butler in der
rolle des king of rock'n'roll tom hanks
spielt seine dubiosen manager tom parker
ich möchte ihr manager sein minister
presley
sind sie bereit zu fliegen ich bin
von musik hat parker keine ahnung doch
er erkennt mit elvis eine goldgrube als
er sieht wie die damenwelt auf dessen
hüftschwung reagiert
[Musik]
parker war ein billiger ganove der auf
schnelles geld aus war
trotzdem hat er zunächst alle glücklich
gemacht nur dass er ganz nebenbei alle
auch elvis ein bisschen abgezockt und
viel geld in die eigene tasche gesteckt
hat
[Applaus]
er hatte keine ahnung was er getan hat
die schwierige beziehung zwischen parker
und elvis schien mir perfekt zu sein um
das amerika der 50er 60er 70er jahre zu
beleuchten und den rassismus jener zeit
ich wollte ein großes amerika gemälde
mal dass auch reflektiert wo wir heute
stehen
[Musik]
tragisch aber das hat nichts mit uns zu
tun das hat alles mit uns zu tun
leute was nicht ins gefängnis stecken
wegen der art wie ich mich bewege ich
komme ins gefängnis weil ich über die
straße gehe aber du bist ein berühmter
weißer junge
[Musik]
ein weißer der die musik der schwarzen
salon fähig macht damals zu zeiten der
rassentrennung eine provokation
[Musik]
wir hätten keinen biss ohne die musik
und die kultur der schwarzen er wuchs
auf in einem überwiegend
schwarzenviertel das war seine
inspiration er liebte es in die gospel
gottesdienst zu gehen
von den wurzeln bis zu seinem absturz in
den 70er jahren
parkers raffgier gilt mit als grund für
elvis frühen tod mit 42 auch die ehe mit
priscilla konnte ihn nicht retten
ein wilder knallbunter und doch
komplexer ein großartiger film
oscar ralf gespielt von austin butler
[Musik]
standing ovations und endloser jubel in
cannes große emotionen und der segen von
priscilla presley kein film so sagt sie
habe elvis wesen je besser angefangen
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
der heute show und um 0.25 meldet sich
dann gundula gause mit unserem heutigen
update und wir morgen in der champions
league halbzeit um 21.45 bis dahin
wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend kühl geht dieser mai zu ende
und das liegt auch an dieser kaltfront
in diesen stunden den alpenrand erreicht
es wird auch sehr windig das ist ein
nordwestwind und diese kalte luft flutet
ganz deutschland heute nacht gibt es
schauer und gewitter in norddeutschland
sonst ist es zum teil auch klar und die
kleine kalt von bringt am alpenrand
regen unter den dichteren wolken ganz im
süden bleibt die nacht recht mild bei 12
bis 10 grad zehn grad geht es heute
nacht auch an der nordsee sonst aber
doch überall einstellige werte zwischen
9 und 4 grad und in den mittelgebirgen
reicht vielleicht sogar nochmal für
bodenfrost und kühl doch morgen über tag
mit höchstwerten zwischen 13 und 17 grad
und allenfalls ermitteln und am
oberrhein geht auf 18 bis 20 grad drauf
morgen vormittag kann es am alpenrand
noch etwas länger regnen dann lockern
auch dort die wolken auf es gibt morgen
so ein mix aus sonne wolken regen
schauern vielleicht ganz vereinzelt auch
mal blitz und donner die kräftigsten
schauer gibt es aber wohl zwischen
berlin und nordfriesland bei einem
starken bis stürmischen wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen an diesem
wetter wird sich auch am sonntag wenig
ändern es wird noch eine spur kühler
dann aber in der neuen woche wird es
doch von tag zu tag wärmer am mittwoch
das ist der meteorologische sommer
beginn steigen die hätte schon bis 29
grad und hier am trend für garmisch
partenkirchen sehen sie dass die
temperaturen sich von samstag 11 grad
auf 30 grad am donnerstag katapultieren
guten abend